The fate of the universe lies on your shoulders.
Now, whatever you do...
...don't... push... this... button.
Because that will set off the bomb immediately           and we'll all be dead.
[scandalised gasp]
Now, repeat back what I just said.
I am Groot.
No! No, that's the button that will kill everyone!
Try again.
I am Groot.
No!
Showtime, a-holes!
Screw you, space shits!
Does anybody have any tape out there?
I want to put some tape over the death button.
-Nobody has any tape!
-Not a single person has tape?!
You have an atomic bomb on your bag!
If anybody's going to have tape, it's you!
-I have to do everything!
-You are wasting a lot of time!
I am Groot!
That's a really bad sign.
If I touch someone, I can feel their feelings.
You feel... love!
Yeah, I guess I feel a general unselfish love for just about...
-No! Sexual love!
-No! No, I don't!
-For her!
-No!
She just told everyone your deepest, darkest secret!
Dude, come on! I think you're overreacting a little bit.
You must be so embarrased!
Do me! Do me, do me!
Hey, Youtubers.
I am Groot, we are Groot.
New guardians footage. Let's break it down.
And there is a new round of the Spider-Man
giveaway going on.
So all you do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Be sure to click the bell to turn alerts on
so you don't miss anything.
So, giant space tentacle monsters! Marvel Phase 3
is like full Rick and Morty: maximum tentacle.
It's like the Cronenberg universe.
This is basically like the interdimensional being
that James Gunn explained
that the team is hired to take down by Ayesha,
played by Elizabeth Debicki.
They have this really weird relationship
where she belongs to this  genetically perfect race
that's super uptight.
Things go sideways, then she ends up coming after Peter Quill and the Guardians.
But like this is like one of the big action set pieces here when they go all cray.
You can see Dax just stabbing the crap out of it.
It's just so hilarious.
So, if you couldn't tell from all the baby Groot
that they put in this,
they're just trying to imply
the tone, the humor...
and give you an idea for how the upped the scale.
So, there's a whole lot we don't see in here
but we're one step closer to seeing Ego
because we see Mantis, who has been living with Ego her whole life.
She's Peter Quill's half-sister by Ego, the living planet.
So, I know that just sounds mind-boggling.
So don't worry about that they'll totally
explain how he made himself a human body
and was able to procreate with the human woman
but Gunn has just said that, thematically,
the way he works in the film
is that he's this ancient being
like we learned in the last film.
Peter Quill has ancient DNA in  him.
And he's been so lonely like he's been a living planet.
How many other living planets
do you know about in the universe.
So, being so lonely,
that's why he made himself a human body
so that he could make himself a family.
Family is like one of the biggest things about this movie,
finding your biological family,
like, Peter Quill searching for his father;
the Guardians themselves as a family...
Like the family you make for yourself
versus the family are born into.
So if you want to, you could consider
Ego, the living planet,
the big villain of the film. But in terms of actual villains that you would actually go up against,
you have the Ravagers, like we saw in the first trailer.
They mutiny against Yondu,
so the Guardians have to help him escape.
That forms the basis for why Yondu
is part of the Guardians.
He was part of the original Guardians team in the comics. So now he looks more like original Yondu
and he's doing more original Yondu things.
But Michael Rooker's going to be crazy in this. So it''ll be a lot of fun.
They still haven't said anything about Sylvester Stallone's mystery performance,
but he wears a Ravagers uniform but I think he goes beyond being a normal Ravager.
But speaking of which... They put baby Groot
in a tiny-baby Ravagers uniform.
You just see him go crazy through most of the trailer.
So this is kind of like the trailer that you would show off to like little kids to.
I feel like they kept him a little baby
just for the younger audience,
just because you see so many little kids
going to comic book conventions
dressed with like baby Groot cosplay.
So keeping him a baby for most of the film,
maybe not the entire film but most of the film,
allows them to have a little bit more fun.
Like: "Don't press this little red
button that is going to kill everybody."
But, if you haven't read the comics,
Groot is effectively immortal.
As long as you have like a little piece of his bio matter.
He can completely regrow himself
from even the littlest of twigs
but they said in the movie he won't
have most of original Groot's memories
but he's effectively the same Groot.
You're getting a Groot
with a vastly different personality,
but effectively it's the same character,
the "We are Groot" type person.
So there will probably be a moment in this
like there was in the first film
and I do think we'll see him grow
towards the end of the film,
but for most of it
he's probably going to be dancing baby Groot.
But it actually doesn't take him that long
to regrow himself in the comics.
Like he could actually do it
in a relatively short amount of time.
A lot of you have also
probably noticed that Nathan Fillion
has a cameo as Wonder Man in the movie,
that they have a slightly different
spin on the character but it is Wonder Man from the comics.
He had a  cameo in the first film
but he was like a full-CG character
So, you really just had to listen to his voice
to know that it was him,
but this time you actually see his face on camera.
But the other big thing they're selling this romance between Star Lord and Gamora.
-No, I don't.
-For her!
No!
She just told everyone your deepest, darkest secret!
Dude, come on! I think you're overreacting a little bit.
You must be so embarrased!
Do me! Do me, do me!
They kind of had some chemistry in the comics
but they haven't really been doing that recently.
They had adventures with Captain Marvel,
Ironman joined them for a while...
They're kind of mixing and matching them
with other Marvel mainstream characters
but we won't actually see the Guardians
with the other Avengers
'till Infinity War.
And otherwise it looks really good.
Like it obviously took them a long time
to get these special effects down.
The movie's been done for a while
but they still had to do post-production.
so let me know you guys think.
I just I love the way James Gunn uses color,
he has a really good sense of humor,
he has a really clear idea for the story
he wants to tell
so the narrative usually doesn't get too muddied down,
like it doesn't fall into a lot of the tropes
of big superhero films
that you saw earlier this year
with films that probably got released
before they were ready to be.
One of the most fun things about
James Gunn though... like I mean is a great filmmaker
but is also really vocal, he has
like a really strong connection with the fandom.
So he is like a lifelong comic book nerd.
So I just feel like that helps him
make really good comic book movies
because he understands the characters
and he understands the way comic books work.
So just a reminder that this is coming out May 2017.
They'll probably do like another big Super Bowl trailer.
There'll probably be some Spider-Man: Homecoming before then, too,
Star Wars Episode VIII
will probably be held for celebration...
They might do a Super Bowl trailer
but now the were like approaching the end of the year
everybody is just like blowing it up for 2017.
The amount of awesome stuff
that's happening next year is unbelievable.
Even the TV stuff, too. It's just off the charts.
Let me know what kind of Guardians of the Galaxy bonus videos
you guys want me to do
while we wait for more stuff to drop.
There are just so many characters,
the stories are so different
from the Earth-based A vengers stories.
So there's all kinds of stuff that we can talk about.
Mr. McTigue!
You win this round  of the Spider-Man giveaway.
It's a $30 Comixology gift card.
I'm trying to like slowly hypnotize everybody
into reading more comics.
So you guys can let me know if it's working,
if you started reading comics more recently.
But there is a new round going on right now.
I'll announce the winner
the next time I post a Marvel video.
And in related news, there was a Last of Us 2 trailer
that just dropped.
So if you guys want to do a video for that,
just let me know in the comments.
It's actually a pretty rad game.
While you wait for that to post, you can click here
for my Doctor strange carnage theory
and you can click here for my breakdown
of the Spider-Man footage they showed at Comic-Con.
Thank you so much watching.
Everybody, let's high five. I'll see you guys tonight!